we begin this half-hour with trouble in
paradise for hundreds of tourists many
of them were left gasping as they
watched one massive cruise ship slamming
to another and nearly hit 1/3 on Friday
the terrifying scene unfolded while one
ship was docking at the popular Mexican
result resort island of Cozumel
but as Manuel Bojorquez reports
incidents like these have happened
before
shocked passengers had their cameras
rolling the moment the Carnival cruise
ship glory smashed into another carnival
ship legend the glory was attempting to
dock in Cozumel Mexico at one point
passengers on a Royal Caribbean ship
thought it would strike them too but it
did not the collision between the two
carnival ships left extensive damage to
the dining room decks of the glory
that's crazy
the cruise line said six passenger
suffered minor injuries Peter Greenberg
is CBS news travel editor suddenly a 30
knot squall showed up at the most
critical time of that particular
maneuver and there was no way for that
captain to recover he calls it a
maritime fender bender if you look at
that video but you probably don't see is
the captain going in full reverse and
still moving forward it takes a while
for any ship to stop there was a
collision in 2009 at the same port and
just this summer in Venice Italy a
cruise ship lost control crashing into a
dock and another boat injuring five
people the carnival ships involved in
yesterday's collision set off from New
Orleans and Tampa with a combined 6,000
passengers the cruise line says both
ships are still seaworthy and the
cruises will continue as planned for CBS
this morning Saturday and while
Bojorquez Miami I realize that squalls
happen right and nobody wanted this
particular thing to happen the collision
but still don't you have to account for
the fact that something wild might
happen with the weather so maybe stay a
little bit farther away
well maybe now they will maybe maybe
they will enough that lesson learned
it's scary to watch yeah yeah how many
people are on board it's a cruise ship
it's huge
it's when I'm 30 yeah
you